da schlappschwanz du sagt gesicht dass
wir keine eier
[Musik]
kann man sich das vorstellen also eine
sexuelle belästigung durch eine frau
also es gab zb männer die geschildert
haben dass ihm gewalt angetan wurde
durch eine frau dass sie geschlagen
wurden wie sieht das aus zum sex
gezwungen zb das müsste ich dafür tun um
vom schauen
ich sollte mich nicht ich glaube da muss
man gar nicht was mache ich falsch dass
ich nicht belästigt werden
da muss man nur auf einen bestimmten
typus frau stoßen ich frage anders was
fehlt mir fehlt vielleicht eine gewisse
frechheit eine gewisses draufgängertum
oder was fehlt mir vielleicht werden sie
von den frauen vielleicht reden die
untereinander und sagen oder kasten da
kann nix abnimmt du schlappschwanz du
satt gesicht dass du keine eier kann es
sein dass ich in bestimmten situationen
männer zu aufreizend anziehen
also ich habe noch keinen mann erlebte
er mir also die wo es mir schien er sei
zu freizügig aber ich habe viele frauen
erlebt wo ich denke ganz schön gewagt
und kommst du mit den reaktionen auch
zurecht ich sage mal ganz persönlichen
fall weihnachtsfeier rotalge kollegin
kommt zu mir so bis hin und sagt carsten
altes drei weinen
denkt immer schön dran
rostiges dach macht einen feuchten
keller eine frechheit
und wenn man das gleiche umgekehrt macht
ich fand es ist unverschämt aber ich
kenne eine auch eine rothaarige die hat
die sanierte sportkneipe für tine und
hat gesagt auch wenn ich dann wird man
bier schon los ich ziehe einfach was
anständiges andere das ist mein schönes
dekolleté sehen kann und dann kaufen die
männer schon dass wir vielen dank frau
überlingen und ich glaube nach diesen
schlimmen geschichten hatte ich
irgendwie das gefühl ich möchte jetzt
duschen alles geboten